we are live chairman
thank you good evening and welcome to
this
northwestern area planning committee
meeting on wednesday the 13th of january
my name is counselor this is maddie
thompson i'm the chairman of this
committee
um i will at this point just mention
that i spent the afternoon in the
dentist's chair so if i fall over my
teeth
i'm afraid it there's a reason for that
they're ill my
face is a bit numb still right to
continue this meeting is held under
regulations which came into effect on
fourth of april in response to the
covert 19 pandemic
there are just a few housekeeping issues
to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
in the meeting to make sure your
microphone remains muted when you're not
addressing the committee to reduce
background noises and avoid any
unintentional disturbances
the meeting is going to be hosted
remotely by conferencing software
which allows members of the public to
virtually attend the meeting
while being able to protect themselves
and others and observe the current
lockdown measures
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each time
each
item please use the hands up function of
the meeting to indicate
if you wish to speak i will then invite
you at the appropriate time
members are invite a reminder that apart
from points of order
or indicating that you must leave the
meeting the chat
function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible when
invited to speak please ensure you turn
on your microphone
and video if possible right now mask
office is taking part in meeting to
introduce themselves starting with mr
lee
good evening members i am matthew lee
and i'm lead professional
place and chief planning officer at
morgan district council thank you
thank you mr johnson
good afternoon members my name is
michael johnson lead specialist
development management
thank you thank you mr lawrence
you're muted mr lawrence
can you unmute please yes okay good
evening members sorry about the delay
um i'm the interim development
management team leader
thank you and miss miss kane annie kane
good evening members i'm annie keane
senior caseworker development management
thank you and ms parker haynes
good evening members i'm hayley
parker-haynes and i'm a senior
caseworker in development management
thank you miss bowles
do we have miss polls hannibals
oh i think and good evening my name is
and i'm a specialist in development
management thank you thank you
um i have sophie martin on my list but i
believe she's not here
is that right could someone confirm that
that's correct she's not here today
thank you and last but not least uh
committee clerk katie
good evening members my name is katie
fuller i'm clark to this evening's
committee
thank you before i call on the clerk to
take the roll caller committee members
can i please ask those counselors in
attendance
to introduce themselves
is there anyone we're not doing this the
normal way round
but um so if there is anyone who's
attending out of interest
and and not as a member of this
particular committee
could you possibly speak it's chrissie
morris in the place
thank you councillor morris uh right i
think you're the only one so let's move
on to the roll call
um casey could you carry out the roll
call of members to confirm
members of the committee in attendance
yes chairman uh members i'll call your
name in alphabetical order please could
you indicate if you are present
starting with councillor dharam
present thank you good evening
uh council mrs fleming
yeah thanks katie thank you
um councillor jarvis
evening kt councillors good evening
councillor keys good evening katie
um chairman and councillors i'm present
good evening councillor morley good
evening katie present
good evening councillor sudo good
evening katie present
good evening this is thompson you're
here
oh definitely thank you councillor miss
white
uh good evening kt members i'm present
good evening thank you councillor
thompson we have a full house
thank you very much um members
please be advised that we have five
public participants in the meeting today
and i will be asking them to speak of
course at the appropriate time
um but they are in the meeting until we
get to their spot
um apologies for absence um we have none
i take it katie
no we have none okay thank you so item
three on our agenda is recommended that
the minutes of the meeting held on 16th
of december found on
pages 7-16 are approved as a true and
accurate
record i so move if you wish to second
that motion
um please unlike unmute your microphone
and state your name now
okay uh i think i've got councillor
darren person but um
anyone anyone is fine if any
any member wishes to raise any matter of
accuracy
please use the hands up function to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
i'm not seeing any okay um members can
we take
these minutes um by a cent agreed by a
cent
agreed upgrade wonderful thank you very
much members
right item four i have to read all of
this out i'm afraid
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become
where should the need arise through the
meeting if any member has an interest to
declare please use the hands up function
now to indicate
mine hang on i've got a hand up here
yes i know i could've got you counseling
yes of course
um i have um a peculiar interest in
items six
and nine okay thank you so you
really need to know do i go out of the
meeting of those
and then someone calls me to come and
then we'll pull you back in yes
yes you do need to leave all together
i'm afraid
that's how it works okay thank you and
counselor mrs fleming
thank you chair um i'd like to declare
a non-pecuniary in item five
um i know the family well um
so it's the relationship's sufficiently
close uh so i feel it's not appropriate
for me to
take part in the debate or vote and then
i wanted to clarify on agenda item
nine last time we had a similar
application
um there i didn't take part
because of a historic financial
relationship
but having discussed with the monitoring
officer
it's no longer relevant and it's
historic so
i'm told that i can take part in the
debate and vote
thank you okay thank you and councillor
darren please
uh thank you very much i have a nonpuny
interest as a member of essex county
council
who are statutory consultees in several
planning considerations thank you
chairman
thank you um could you just pop your
hands back down again if you haven't
already
lovely thank you right then moving on to
our first planning application it's
agenda item five
little grange farm mulpitz road wood and
mortimer
and we have
looking for public speakers no
speakers not for this one okay thank you
so much king could you present a report
please
thank you chair
planning permission is sought for the
change of use of
agricultural bonds to a c3 dwelling
house
along with associated operational
development
this is the location plan showing the
proposed site outlined in red
this is the existing and proposed block
plan
the plan on the left shows the existing
site
with the building to be demolished and
the buildings to be retained
and the plan on the right shows proposed
development
these are the existing elevations
showing the two barns
to be converted into the dwelling and
the barn to be demolished which is
outlined in red
these are the proposed elevations
these the existing floor plans
these are the proposed floor plans
game was previously refused at this site
for conversion of the existing barns
into live work units and the erection of
two outbuildings
these are the photos of the site showing
the barn's subject of the current
application
the application is recommended for
refusal due to resultant intensification
of residential development
which would substantially alter the
character of the area and have an
unacceptable visual
visual impact upon the countryside
through the urbanization
and domestication of the site
additionally there is an absence of a
completed legal agreement
to secure a financial contribution
towards the mitigation of environmental
harm caused by the development as
required by the essex coastal rams thank
you chairman
thank you um
right the recommendation is um
as we've just heard is that the planning
application be refused for the reasons
detailed in section 8 of the report if
any
member wishes to second that motion
please let me know
any money i'll second that thank you
councillor
just for the benefit of anyone listening
um a proposal or a second
is is not a commitment to vote in favor
um just in case anyone thinks we've
decided beforehand what we're doing
um so board member
councillor daruma or councillor jarvis
who wishes to go first
i'm i'm quite happy too um chairman
i'm i'm not going to be protracted on
this um as you can see
um in 8.2 the reasons for refusal this
is contrary to the local development
plan
um it's also given the absence of a
five-year land supply where we have to
uh consider the presumption in favor of
sustainable development it doesn't tick
the boxes in the nppf either
and i think for the reasons that the
officers have given
i i do agree that this application
should be refused
thank you okay thank you
i'm the ward member that called it in
chairman
yes you are i'm coming to you next
council jarvis
okay um i've had a look through the
application i mean
i know that there was a previous
application that was refused on this
site but i mean that was for
four dwellings and uh obviously this is
a different application
i mean i am familiar with the site i
think it's quite complex so
could we just get the photographs back
up again i think that would be helpful
okay so so if i can just look at the
bottom right foot
of what we were just looking at there
the first set so the first one yeah the
bottom right photograph there i mean
that's an asbestos bar which is coming
down
it looks most unsightly it's not
currently used
i don't think anybody would disagree
that the removal of that bomb would
actually improve
uh the views that anybody might see so
just to be clear because there's a bit
it's a bit complex the application so
that barn
is coming down it's mainly asbestos
clever cladding
when that barn comes down behind it and
i think you can see in the top left-hand
photograph it's that middle barn
middle barn is a very narrow
old 17th century thrashing barn
and that bomb will will stay and
actually from the front
at the moment so bottom right hand
photograph you can't see that lovely
barn it's hidden
so when this barn is demolished what
you'll then be able to see
is a very nice 17th century
barn which will just improve the look
now
the other main aspect that's going on is
obviously
the conversion of the fruit apple bar
which is
the top right barn you can see there and
in the
in the left-hand picture it's the one
one with the turrets on the top
that's an old um apple barn which hasn't
been used for some 30 years obviously
when the farm was
an apple based farm so that's currently
a building which is not used at all and
it seems to me that if obviously the
applicant
wishes to convert that tastefully
without
altering the exterior appearance too
much into
a dwelling that would be
something that we should look favorably
on because obviously
we should be looking to make good use of
the land and good use of an existing
site
uh where currently it's obviously of no
use whatsoever
so top right hand barn i think uh
is the may would be the new dwelling and
i think it's important to understand
that
uh looking through the plans that this
isn't this isn't a case of
taking down the barn and putting
something up that's different this
is going to look substantially like it
does at the moment very tastefully
using taking off any asbestos tiles
replacing them with something that's
aesthetically similar
leaving some turrets and putting crittal
windows in
so very a very tasteful design uh
in terms of that property so i i have to
say
uh without further ado chairman i've
looked at this
and tried to see how this gives harm to
the countryside because
i think overall this will look
substantially better
i don't think there'll be any
substantial urbanization
it's not the previous application this
is just one property
and i think making good use of an
existing
redundant building hasn't been used for
30 years
is something we should be keen to
support
thank you chairman thank you councillor
white
oops thank you ma'am i'll try my
broadband again for as long as it's
going to last
and i have to say i agree with
everything that counselor jarvis has
just said
um i i objected to the four dwellings
because again it was over development
um but i actually think it removes the
harm um
on the area by removing the ugly
asbestos barn
um which are horrible buildings and as
we all know
uh they need to go and they need to have
to be disposed of correctly because of
what they're made of
um i would also propose that we put a
condition on that they signed the
section 106 agreement i think it's only
a payment of 150 pounds it's nothing too
um too onerous and i would have thought
that this barn would have been permitted
development anyway because it was
historically used for agriculture with
the apples
so i don't know why it's not actually
here as bruce development it's a totally
different application the last one we
don't have a five-year land supply and i
absolutely
think they should be approved and i'm
happy to propose um an alternative
decision when we come to that stage
thank you madam chairman okay
thank you um mr lee did you want to come
back on any of that
at the stage
i'm happy to come back now i can wait or
wait if other members have any more
questions
okay okay
um let's move on to the counselor keys
then please
oh god um could i see the site plan
again please
the outline boundary is it
all in one boundary
right so that's all that red area
is owned by the same person correct
that would be the site in question yes
site looking for the application there
might
there would be a blue line for land in
the ownership they're probably in the
same place actually
right and the same exit
entrance or exit whenever you want to
put it to the house is the same exit to
the barn
correct
uh yes it would be right so
how far is it from the house to
the said x apple shed that's gonna
which they would like to turn into a
house what is the distance between
the two properties
about 20 meters about 20 meters
so i know this is a different
application but
a few weeks ago we done an annex which
was
a lot a bit further than that i can't
see
i'm happy to happy to um
second day um or i'd put a proposal that
i think we should
cancel on this but i can't see it as a
problem no one in their right mind if
they're in the house wouldn't be able to
want to sell the place away from it it's
all the red line which
i believe i'm told to believe it's all
owned by the same person
and i think i'm making a good use of an
old barn
yeah i can't say unless anybody can tell
me that there's another access in there
to say the place could be
turned away but by the looks of that
outline i can't see any other
accesses in or out of the property
so yes i think it's okay good thank you
thank you uh councillor dharam did you
come back with their legacy hand
well i did unless there's anybody else
other members wanting
to say anything and as well is that a
legacy
she's already had her go if i have my
second i'll have my second go if that's
okay
you know yes i i i agree with nearly
everything councillor jarvis and other
members have said
yes it would be a good thing to lose the
asbestos barn
and it would certainly improve the
ascetics
but we're coming back to policy again
and it is very clear it is contrary to
our
not only our adopted local development
plan
but even taking into account the fact
that we
um don't have a five-year land supply at
the moment it's also contrary to the
nppf
now we sat through um a briefing
yesterday
by the planning officers who made it
extremely clear that every decision
we're taking against policy and i
understand all of the
the arguments about treating every case
at its own merits and i'm all for that
we are absolutely giving
this authority really significant
issues in the future that is indefinable
and now mr lawrence who it's a pleasure
to see back
i think he was the head of planning when
we were going through the ldp
so nobody would know more than mr
lawrence about the implications
of us constantly
agreeing things contrary to the local
development plan we may as well not have
one
and and i have total sympathy with the
applicant and i have total sympathy
with uh with with all of the arguments
given
but you know we are just we are we are
driving ourselves up a one-way
road with no way back and we will end up
paying for this
i'm very sorry but you know that is the
situation and i'm sure mr lawrence and
mr lee
will confirm that and if members are
minded to agree this
then fine but we don't want to be he's
in a position in a year or two's time
where we are we are having the problems
that will result from this and we are
going to be forced into granting
permissions
for properties we do not want in places
that we do not want them
because that certainly will be the
outcome thank you chairman thank you
very much
all right i have counsellor councillors
white and councillor jarvis however what
i'm going to say is this
this business of
viewing each case on its own merits this
isn't the merits according to how we
view it this is the merits according to
the policies
so whereas we are entitled to weigh up
policies
maybe with different weights than um our
officers do
we're not actually entitled there is no
democratic right to decide that the
policies
don't count so councillor white
thank you madam chairman i just want to
come back and say that um
in actual fact we've already set a
policy for change of use of barns
because i know in the last six months
we've had the change of use of maybe
six or seven different barns and the
last one was um
near champions lodge um i think it's in
councillor jarvis's ward and that was
nothing like as beautiful a building as
this one will be and i think this will
enhance the different and we have
already
set a president for passing agricultural
buildings into residential
and and by their by their their their
thing they're not
in a sustainable location but it's no
less sustainable than any others so
you know i i'm sorry i disagree with
them
councillor durham okay thank you
councillor jarvis um just very briefly
if you would please if you have any new
points but we
we can't be doing with any more
three-hour meetings i've just got three
points to make if i made quickly
chairman i mean i attended the training
session as well
on the national planning policy
framework and i was keen to hear
that making effective use of land is
clearly
one of the environment economic or
social uh
items for sustainability under that
framework so this is undoubtedly making
effective use of land
we're going to be taking down an old
barn which is uh
of no use whatsoever we're going to be
showing the whole public and anybody
else that can see it a new
a 17th century barn that look wonderful
and they're going to make use of a
building that hasn't really been used
for 30 years so i think it's going to
look attractive it's going to make
effective use of the land
i was at the parish meeting when they
debated this
and the whole parish people who actually
live there
they think this is a wonderful idea this
whole site i have to say
is um surrounded by um you know a lot of
distance
there's a lot of distance the people who
own this site are in some of the
surrounding fields and everybody else
that can see this uh thinks it's going
to be
a fantastic development they're the
people who live there and they're the
people i feel we should pay some
attention to
when we're looking at uh whether it's
going to detract or not from the
countryside
and when we look at the effective use of
land so okay
thank you chad right thank you uh ryan
mr lee that's giving you some
something to come back with i think
thank you chairman um i'll try and keep
it short um
firstly though um obviously if i like
i won't quite deal with them in the
order that they were presented to myself
because
obviously if just take members to
the header of the piece of
the report and and the application is
full planning application for the
purpose of change of views from
agriculture dwelling house c3 so in
relation to councillor keys point this
is actually an application for a
dwelling it's not for an annex
it will be subdivided and sold off
potentially because it is for a separate
independent dwelling so
that's correct um incorrect to imply
that it will
function as an annex because that is not
what the planning application is for
and as members fully aware because
because you've heard me say it a million
and one times you know we have to look
at the application for the lifetime not
just for who may
own it now or in the short term you know
we have to look for the fact that could
happen in 10 15 20 years time
um moving on um
i know points raised about and a barn
coming down
and that there you know that this may
improve the views and
allow for a view of another barn i think
professional advice for that should be
given minimal weight in the uh
assessment of application when you look
at the conflict with the guidance within
the mppf and within our own policies
um which really strongly
persuade or try to guide decision-making
away from
uh provision of weddings in rural areas
that are not close to
the day-to-day facilities that are
needed for living
and you know as the office report comes
in detail this site is
exactly one an example of that um
the fact that the barn hasn't been used
for 30 years to sometimes should be a
moot point
um our policy does allow for reuse of
agricultural buildings but that does not
promote at any stage the reuse for
residential
for residential use and that is
something that is also supported by the
mppf
so um to echo what the chairman said
council thompson
um each application must be termed on
its own merits but
the starting point is the development
plan unless material considerations
indicate otherwise
it's the interpretation those policies
should be consistent whether it's
officers members which committee
because they're a clear requirement and
once again it feels that the actual
content of the policies is not being
given any real weight in the assessment
if there appears to be quite a
strong presumption in personal feeling
which is not what we're here to
determine applications in
this is a quasi-judicial process where
policies aren't the starting point
unless material situations indicate
otherwise um
you know as councillor durham said you
know each application
will potentially be used against us to
basically summarize what he said um
and the statement that was
made by members today almost would imply
that any agricultural building
um is allowed to um be used for
us so every coach building can be
submitted and converted into a dwelling
without and that would be policy
compliant unfortunately that is not what
our policy states and it'd be a very
dangerous
precedent to make to you use that as an
argument
um once again i'd also highlight that
i'd say the fact that it's considered to
be a tasteful to
design i'm not really substantially
change the appearance of the building it
didn't really carry much weight in my
advice and determination this
application
relation to councilwhite's point about
permitted development um
couldn't comment one way the other
because they haven't submitted a prior
approval
um obviously if they had that
legislation
it's separate to us plan application and
obviously
officers would have happily assessed
that but that isn't in front of us so
without an agreement on that through the
submission of an application
or all of them or anything like that i
think the potential for that should be
given
limited weight in the termination of
this application um
in relation to the
council of dom's point about we might as
well not have a local plan
to certainly you know it wouldn't matter
because
this point is the policies are
completely consistent with the mpp if we
didn't have a local plan we would be
determined by the mppf alone
and the mppf is clear that dwellings
in remote locations are not acceptable
and that is what this application is so
um whether we had an mp if we had the
local plan on the mpp if it wouldn't
matter as in we would be
getting a recommendation for refusal
from officers in this aspect
um um in relation to comments about
making better use of land
that i could not say that the mppf in my
official opinion at no stage
does it say that the use of agricultural
fields or agriculture buildings for
residential dwellings is a better use of
land it's clear about
you the use of mp brownfield land um
clear about within settlement boundaries
etcetera but it does not encourage
anywhere within the uh mppf of the
general presumption of converting
agricultural buildings to residential
dwellings
um finding relations points raised
the fact that the parish meeting may
have been supportive and that members of
public
in close proximity may be keen on the
development is not a material
consideration case law is clear
and i think members need to be very
conscious of that very conscious what
they say in the
in debates when there is quite clear
case law that
makes points such as that and popularity
of an application either
for or against is not material
consideration
you need to consider the material
considerations of the application of
policies
government guidance planning history etc
and once again i'll just
state again popularity application is
not a material situation
and the only other thing i'd like to
quickly raise chairman is that um
the reason for refusal one
one relates to both the impacts on the
character there but also on
sustainability in relation to access to
facilities and
while members have raised some argument
in
relation to some betterment for the
appearance and you know
they may be trying to argue that the
harm from
the increased residential development
will be offset by the views of the barn
etc there's been no discussion about
the access to day-to-day facilities they
need to use private car
this is a very very remote site and
we need to as an authority be taking a
consistent approach and as cancer dumb
said you know
if we don't do that you'll be making
officers
position very difficult for future
dwellings especially as we haven't got a
five-year land supply
if we start to say that remote locations
like this are acceptable for residential
dwelling
thank you chairman thank you uh
councillor durham is that
a legacy hand because i'd really like to
go on to a vote
it isn't a legacy hand uh chairman i
i've got a request very very quickly
yes i would yes but i would like uh i
would like this statement put on record
please
uh that if this committee uh agree this
plan the application
it will be contrary to the local
development plan and aspects of the
national
planning policy framework and as such
will be contrary to the law regarding
the determination of planning
applications by a local planning
authority
and i think it's very important that
members understand the implications of
that but i would
like that placed on record please thank
you okay thank you
i know you've got your hand up again
councillor white but i think i would
like to vote on the recommendation and
then we'll take it from there
[Music]
um okay
uh katie could we have four uh a vote a
roll call
please for the recommendation to refuse
or against or of course abstentions
thank you
yes chairman members i'll take your name
in alphabetical order
please could you indicate whether you
are for against or abstaining
starting with councillor durham please
you're muted counselor this is the
decision for the refusal of the
application
yes this is this is this is uh we're
voting for
the officer's recommendation um i i vote
for thank you
thank you councillor mrs fleming
katie i'm sitting this way apologies
yes thank you councillor jarvis
i'm against the officer's recommendation
thank you
councillor keys i'm also against the
officer's recommendation
thank you councillor morley i'm against
councillor four thank you
councillor mrs thompson paul
thank you councillor miss white
against
chairman thank you so the rec sorry
casey
please give us the numbers sorry i'm
jumping in fine you have three
four and four against with no
abstentions
okay thank you so that is lost so i need
uh to move on i need a proposal to
presumably do the opposite
and i need that to be with
reasons please okay well council jarvis
has his hands up and he did call it in
so let's um let's hear it from council
jarvis please
thank you chairman i'm happy but to
propose the application
uh on the basis that it makes effective
use of land
uh it's no no uh material harm at all to
the countryside
um those would be an effective use of an
existing site
um they would be some of the reasons i
would give chairman
okay i believe we're not quite there
we're not quite there because councillor
jarvis you need to address
the reasons for refusal as given in the
report not just give different reasons
so you need to explain um you need to
justify in regards to the
or sustainability credentials etc sorry
chairman can i also highlight that
um our actual adopted policy does not
accept that the reuse for agricultural
building
is an effective use of land our policy
that does deal with that clearly states
that that isn't and that's something
that's been supported at numerous
appeals so
statements such as that would be a
hundred percent conflicting with both
our policy
planning history for this site within
the district
and would be very dangerous to start to
make decisions based on that because it
is completely conflicting and would then
imply that
any agricultural building could be used
as a dwelling or any
any piece of land could be used as a
building because that would be a more
appropriate use than agricultural use
which is
a very dangerous decision based on the
nature of our district that's what i
just advise members
right i hear what you're saying but i
can only ask
ask councillor jarvis to reconsider that
and
sustainability thank you chairman i mean
i was just
just uh making a remark that came up in
the training session that we recently
had on the national
policy planning framework effective use
of land was given by officer lee
clearly as one of the reasons so i'm
just using that
that seems to make sense to me he's the
professional but seems to me that
uh as far as sustainability issues are
concerned
i i i'm not
this property is not in the middle of a
town it is fairly isolated
nobody is denying that um obviously they
could use bikes if they wanted to go
somewhere look
it's in the country nobody's saying it
isn't in the country
um i i think the main reason i thought
that was given
by the officer for
not wanting to to refuse this property
was because it was a detrimental effect
on the countryside that was the main
reason given
i just simply don't think that's the
case
i think it has a negligible impact on
the countryside in fact if anything
all development as obviously told us in
the training session
all developments of any any sort will
always have to a degree
an effect on the countryside but this
really will have negligible effect
um the the building it will look
substantially the same
um the removal of other buildings will
probably improve
the look of the countryside so the main
reason given for refusal
uh as i understand it is uh is the
impact on the countryside and i simply
don't think that's the case i think it's
a
poor assessment and it's one of one of
the
reasons i'd like to approve
through your it just for clarity um i'm
sure council jarvis has read the office
report
but just to read the conclusion or the
final line of the conclusion
furthermore due to the location of the
site and the distance to public services
is considered that development would not
be located with us
within a suitable sustainable location
which is also echoed in a much larger
section within the officers report so
although so that needs to also be dealt
and is
contained with the reason for you that
also has to be it's not a case of
the officers of only putting up a slight
reason for refusal you know
as i explained you know it's always
reason for approval is within the
members gift but
i think members need to be very careful
of the wording they use
because these will be used against us
and we are a very
rural district we now we no longer have
a five-year land supply
which means that the decisions that we
make at every committee and office level
that delegated
will be constantly put into the melting
pot to be
a balancing exercise and i think we've
just got to be very conscious of that
members and thank you and i just would
like to keep getting quoted back about
the effective use of land
but that is in relation to certain
aspects that is not
that does not mean any use becomes a
fixed use land because and highlight
that
we have a policy that explains what that
is and residential
development is not that so um you know i
just advise that
regarding sustainability point you know
this is a this is a
uh development which is which is not in
the center of town this is the middle of
the country i don't know
nobody is denying that fact
but i think there are other in terms of
i think
what obviously would describe is the
sort of tilted balance
um there are other aspects which are in
its favor and that those
perhaps i could ask other councillors to
chip in if that's all right
yes i'm driving for a proposal here not
a new debate
so counseling
all i'd like to say is that um we
determine
every application on its own merits and
we believe that the improvement in the
visual impact
actually overweighs the harm of the
sustainable location
and therefore we find this application
um
uh suitable for approval or words along
those lines
well it's concise counselor jarvis are
you happy to accept that
yes i think councillor white succinctly
said what i was perhaps struggling to
say thank you councillor white
okay so i think that becomes councillor
white's proposal um i know
council keys was prepared to second it
but with one or other of you please
second it
i thought she was like
[Music]
right now we do need we do need some
conditions
and i'm rather assuming that the legal
agreement
pursuant to the rams it will be included
as they um
sorry as a condition and a counselor
might now that it's your proposal
would you are you prepared to leave the
other conditions to be dealt with in
consultation with
myself as chairman and the board members
absolutely that would be fantastic
unless there's anything special you have
in mind
mr lee is there anything
especially in mind
sorry chairman earth through you well
obviously
um
it wouldn't be that we should be granted
approval because it's for a
what it would be would be that delegated
to officers
be um subject to completion of a section
106 agreement for the uu
for the financial commission so any
recommendation wouldn't be to grant
planning permission anyway it'd be to
delegate to officers subject to
completion of the unilateral undertaking
okay yes you're absolutely right
absolutely right
i do know that i should know that
so i think we're there so we have a
proposal to delegate this
uh to the officers on the basis
of them sorting out the legal agreement
for the reasons as given by councillor
mr white so
we have the vote please kate
um just to check councillor jarvis did
you um
did you leave the meeting or did you
lose your connection at some point
no i've got another connection here
chairman i left them love the main one
but i've got another connection here
okay as long as you weren't missing for
more than a few seconds because that
would mean you couldn't vote
yeah i realized that no i made sure i'd
got two connections so i wouldn't miss
the debate
apologies if that uh i left one of the
mics on
double mic on but apologies for that but
i was here at the museum
right thank you um katie please
thank you um chairman councillors i'll
take your name alphabetical order
this is for the approval counselor
durham please against
thank you councillor jarvis
thank you councillor keys
four plus cody councillor morley
four councillor
against thank you councillor mrs
thompson
again thank you councillor miss white
four thank you chairman that's
four four three against and no
abstentions
okay thank you um so that
is delegated to ultimately be approved
in uh as long as we have the legal
agreement
right moving on item six on our agenda
i'm sorry i'm
having trouble with my mouth here um the
willows brick house road tolson major
um ms parker haynes is going to present
the report
and we do have some speakers on this
so uh thank you ms parker
chairman i've got to leave the meeting
oh yes of course you have yes um
councillor morley and we will invite you
back in before the next one starts
thank
thank you chairman planning permission
is sought for alterations to the
existing kennels and the replacement of
kennels with two log cabins
this is the location plan
these are the existing and proposed
block plans
these are the existing elevations of the
kennels and run to the northern boundary
of the site
these are the proposed elevations and
floor plans of the replacement log
cabins to be used as kennels to the
northern boundary of the site
these are the existing elevations and
floor plans of the kennels to the
southern boundary of the site
these are the proposed elevations and
floor plans of the kennels to the
southern boundary of the site
and these are photographs of the site it
is noted that a number of concerns have
been raised in relation to the number of
dogs to be kept at the site and the
associated noise and odor nuisances
would cause
as discussed in section 5.6 of the
officer report
due to the passage of time it is
considered on the balance of
probabilities that the site has a lawful
sue generous use
incorporating the breeding and kenneling
of dogs
and in this instance the intensification
of this use is not considered to be a
material change of use
and therefore it is considered that to
ensure the use of the site remains
acceptable in planning terms
conditions are imposed to secure details
in relation to odor and noise management
plans
restricting the number of dogs on site
and details in relation to the storage
of refuse and waste
this application is recommended for
approval it is considered that the
proposed works could not harm the
appearance or character of the locality
and due to the relationship with
adjoining properties and the inclusion
of appropriately worded conditions
the proposed development is not
considered to result in any undue harm
by way of overlooking or loss of amenity
to neighbouring residents thank you
chairman thank you
right so our first public speaker is mr
williams so can we get you on your video
and microphone please mr williams
and you have two minutes do we have a
clock katie
uh yes i'll start the timer when um mr
williams starts
speaking mr williams when when we can
see you and you're ready
uh we won't start the clock until you
actually begin to speak and then you
have two minutes
madam chairman um i'm representing the
resident suggestion to the um the
proposed development
the occupants of this property have been
breeding dogs for a number of years
i've lived in my cottage for 25 years
and have never seen any number of dogs
in the
kennels that were supposedly existing
the bleeding was done in the house
so i didn't have a problem with noise or
smell but my neighbors did
because of the extractor fans
my main objection is that the building
the buildings have commenced and
completed in the last few months
without the planning approval and
currently there is a cabin
cabin bay which is on the plans there's
also a dog run which was removed from
the plans in december
um so you're looking at the wrong
application the with the respect
the planning committee are looking at
297.001 revision f
whereas the current plan shown 297.000
in addition the the noise issue
was related to two cabins
which is fine if they were properly
insulated
but you can't have noise management
system in an open mesh
in addition to that
according to your last statement the
code of practice relates to
the number of square meters per buck
so you avoid four square meters per dog
or an additional one a half square
meters for two dogs
which is fine the problem is that
breeding females need eight square
meters
and there's nothing in any of the plans
which gives that space for a breeding
female
in my conclusion the planning committee
is reviewing the wrong application
and the accommodation does not comply
with the
i'm sorry mr williams i have to stop you
there you have used your
two minutes but thank you very much for
that um
now we have um mr tony payne who is the
chairman of the parish council and he is
representing the parish council mr payne
are you ready
mr payne sorry mr williams could you
please turn off your
microphone thank you right mr payne can
we
get you into the meeting yeah you know
oh we can hear you if you have
trouble with your internet connection
and you can't show your video then um
right mr payne you have two minutes from
when you begin to speak
thank you madam chairman um further to
our previously submitted objection
to this application and our subsequent
reading of the committee report
we continue to have concerns regarding
the impact upon neighbouring properties
and believe it is contrary to the
following planning policies
d11d refers to layout
orientation and density we consider the
more easterly positioning
and close proximity of the two new log
cabins within the garden
but in comparison to the existing run be
highly visible to the residents of the
chalet
the increase in size of the garage will
increase the density of development in
the garden
and increase visibility from
neighbouring gardens
d1 d2 refers sorry d12
refers to usable private and public
immunity places
we consider the noise from 18 [ __ ]
plus three stud dogs
will no longer allow the gardens of
nearby neighbours to be usable places
currently most of the dogs at this
property are in the house
it is about 12 years since the existing
run has been occupied by dogs
this application therefore presents a
substantial increase in the noise levels
which will be generated
outdoors this will deny neighbours their
right to quiet enjoyment of their
properties
dy4 refers to the protection of the
surrounding areas in terms of noise
smell and visual impact
we continue to have concerns about the
smell from the garden
and the visual impact and smell from the
replacement waste bins at the front of
the property
in this residential area finally the
report makes reference to policies e4
and h7
which relate to rural employment and
land-based rural businesses
we do not consider that dog breeding is
exclusively a rural enterprise in terms
of employment
or premises and therefore e4 and h7 are
not grounds for approval of this
application
the willow shares a boundary with five
properties including cranbrook cottage
which is incorrectly labeled on the
report's site map
cranbrook is attached to saffron cottage
the world is not an isolated rural
building
therefore this development will have a
detrimental impact on the labor i'm
sorry mr claim
i have to stop you there i'm sorry
you've just run out of time
thank you our third speaker on this
agenda item is mark jackson who is the
agent mr jackson
please um same rules for you
as soon as we get you online and we'll
start the timer for two minutes when you
start to speak thank you
can you all hear me members i can thank
you
everybody else okay yes thank you
right good evening good evening members
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to speak on behalf of mrs
o'connor
the applicant and the owner of the
property willows
the application site includes the
bungalow and the kennels
the business has been operating from
willows for 35 years for dog
reading the use is lawful a variety of
dogs have been bred many of them show
winners
the owners have a molded district
council license for a maximum of 20 dogs
and the business now concentrates on the
breeding of cockapoos
the officer recommendation is to grant
planning permission
the proposal just seeks the replacement
of existing kennels with two log cabins
and the extension and re-roofing of the
kennel to the south of the site
the number of dogs will not change
the application is made to accord with
the animal welfare regulations 2018.
the upgraded materials and insulation
proposed will
further improve local amenity and reduce
potential noise impact the neighboring
pemas
premises my clients agree with the
conditions recommended to you by the
planning officer and environmental
health officer
on page 45 of your agenda
in respect of the suggested condition 5
a noise management plan has been drafted
and will be formally submitted to seek
the discharge of this planning condition
the replacement of the existing kennel
buildings which have been on site for
many years with new
modern and well-insulated kennels will
be a considerable improvement to the
amenities enjoyed by the residents
they have been designed following the
advice of an acoustic
engineer the council environment of a
health officer has advised the council
that he has no objection in principle to
the proposed development
but does not wish the number of dogs to
be increased on the site
officers have addressed this by
suggesting to members the imposition of
planning condition 7
referring to a maximum of 20 dogs
members are invited to grant planning
permission subject to the imposition of
the recommended planning conditions
thank you that's good two minutes thank
you
thank you um right
oh counselor durham i do have you but uh
first i've got a couple of questions
i'm sorry yeah i i i i regret i did
inform you earlier that i know it's very
hard to visit you're more
more important meeting than north west
area planning but i regret there is one
um so i do have to leave you um and i'll
just say yeah thank you very much
uh indeed and i'm sure members will make
the right decisions
thank you and good night everybody thank
you and
good night counselor darren right and
before i go on to any
members can i ask mr lee to just address
this
this business of whether we're looking
at the right plans
or not if you can
i'll be hope if the case officer picks
that up
okay is parker haynes
thank you chairman i can confirm that
the plans provided are are the accurate
plans of what is proposed
of what's proposed but are they accurate
plans
of what's been built given that some of
it has been built
as some of it as you will be aware the
planning system does allow for partially
retrospective applications
so if works have begun that that's not a
material consideration in the
determinant of
determination of the application
no well no i'm i'm with you on that much
as i know all members
hate
um the application is in front of us is
what is in front of us
um we have to determine that term in
this application
if something is being built on site that
doesn't fall within the remit of this
permission
that would be a matter for the planning
enforcement team and subs potentially
subsequently a second submission of an
application
but what we have in front of us is the
application tonight for determination as
submitted
thank you thank you for that
clarification i was wondering if we
should defer
but obviously obviously not um
right members i will have my go quickly
first um as i'm the only ward member who
can speak
on it i've actually called this in
because there is so much
neighbor concern and and i know how
concerned the parish council is um
so i do want to have everything aired or
because
what worries me is that most of the
objections are not
actually planning matters i know
mr lee will bear me out on that which
does put us in a very difficult position
should we turn this down because
anything that can be controlled by
condition i'm sure mr lee will bear me
out
um must be controlled by a condition it
cannot be a reason for refusal
am i right there mr lee
yes chairman that's correct that's
correct so
okay so i i'm going to find it very
difficult
to do anything other than support the
officer's recommendation even though i
understand how the residents feel
i don't think planning is the right way
to address their concerns
right so um
other members wishing to speak please
council siddal
um mr williams has a hand up but um
that's could you take your hand away
please mr williams you don't
get it there isn't another go i'm afraid
for you
sorry councillor siddal please thank you
chairman uh yeah i have
i like you have concerns about this
application and i understand that there
are conditions being put in place in
terms of the planning application
however i i think the impact that it has
and the impact it will yeah the new new
buildings and things like that
have on the surrounding properties
it's not going to be a nice design it's
not going to be something that is
beneficial to the to the other
properties so
i do have concerns about about passing
this application
um i have concerns that they will adhere
to
the limit on 20 dogs and and how we
how can we ensure that gets enforced is
that would be
very very difficult to get enforced
there are lots of issues at the moment
that they aren't aren't following uh the
correct procedure in terms of waste
disposal
and residents around the the
property at the moment the waste is
disposed
in a skip um which in the summer is open
to the air
is is you know there's lots of flies
creates lots of smell
the dogs bark i live probably
half a mile away and at times i can hear
the dogs barking
so there is a huge noise consideration
as well
so i i i'm in in a very difficult
situation in terms of
yeah i can see the reasons why this
shouldn't be passed i can see the
reasons why it should be passed
and um i have lots of concerns about it
and yeah and the fact that they haven't
operated correctly
previously yeah and whether they will
contin will they
whether they will start operating and
and adhere to the conditions that are
being applied
i have great concerns over that thank
you
um yes thank you councillor um yes i
i do too but they're not reasons for
planning refusal
um who else do we have councillor
fleming please
thank you chair i just wanted to ask mr
lee about noise
um noise would be a valid reason for
refusal as i understand it
i don't know has the sort of noise
that's currently there has that been
sort of investigated
in the past have there been complaints
in the past
um i think the the main point there is
that the dogs were previously being kept
in the house but they need more room
sorry mr lee i didn't mean to yeah
that's fine i'm only talking through you
anyway so
i should wait for you to invite me and
i'm probably a little bit too
eager and keen at times um
thank you um
my age is lucky and this time in the
evening you're lucky to get me eager and
keen i suppose what i was going to say
is um
the planning noise is clearly a material
situation in terms of
planning application and it is something
obviously
officers have looked at the site
lawfully
what we can work out has had 20 dogs or
license for 20 dogs so on the balance
probabilities had that
around that for well excessive 10 years
so
the breeding of dogs as a commercial
enterprise on this site
is lawful um as councillor
said there may well already be
experience and noise and issues but
it's not been to such a degree that
environmental health have found it to be
a
statutory nuisance and to take action um
so that is the starting point with any
future application
is the full back positions doesn't
matter whether it was this application
or anything else
always if there was a full-back position
so that's a lawful use or
uh extent permission or whatever we need
to start from there and to consider
what they're proposing now compared to
what is on site
um i know member of public said they're
not really using the existing buildings
for breeding but they have the right to
do that and they could do that tomorrow
without the need for planning permission
those existing buildings probably not
necessarily as
potentially as uh nor is secure
as what a future new building would be
or how we can control it through
condition
so we've got to be minded that those
existing structures on site could be
used for the housing of dogs and the
noise that could
come from that so officers have assessed
this application obviously looked at the
noise
issues and we consider that there's the
potential just like with any
planning application for there to be
noise and in this case you know if we
were to leave it unmitigated it could be
quite bad for one of a better phrase
so what we've looked at and taken into
account is
a number of conditions one would be
um quick condition five which requires
annoying management and noise
management plan to be submitted to the
council
and that that will be approved and that
the details will be fully
implemented before the first use of the
development here by approved so
the fact that even if they have or
haven't started the development actually
in this right matter doesn't really
matter because
if they built the whole building and but
they don't put any dogs in it
there's no noise issue because there's
no dogs in it so
what we want to do is make sure that any
noise is mitigated before that
before they actually has a dog put in
that building so
that's condition five on the record on
the
conditions that we're suggesting um also
in relation to the balance probabilities
everything
officers are conscious that there's
probably been around 20 dogs including
[ __ ] so
on site um historically
the license in theory could be increased
in the future
um i know you could argue it's unlikely
because of you know
standards on the health of the dogs etc
are likely to get more generous not
more restricted but actually we don't
know that so officers
have taken the fairly pragmatic approach
and actually also
recommended a condition that limits the
number of dogs on site for breeding
whether it's dogs or [ __ ]
um to 20 and that is condition
seven so i think personally
professionally those two
conditions would actually mitigate any
noise harm
that would be worse than what's
currently on site or the potential for
what's currently on site because at the
end of the day we can only deal with
future problems we can't deal with
existing problems so
i think in all likelihood the proposal
we've built out
and taking into account the conditions
andy done
appropriately would be less of an impact
in noise than the
existing situation should be um also i'm
speaking anyway to jump
point on relation to cancer civil ways
in relation to uh
older if we're quite aware that
there's been a number of uh issues
raised around and
how it's being stored at the moment and
we've imposed a condition
under condition or recommending the
condition under condition six which
requires
uh details of how refusing waste will be
stored
and that that will be implemented and
will be dealt with
um in relation to council seattle's
point about enforcement
um we
you know we can only enforce what we can
enforce and if we've got conditions we
can enforce it um
at the moment there are no planning
restrictions on the site so there is
nothing
planning could do in relation to
enforcement of that be waste noise odour
um and amenity in planning terms is a
much
lower harmful standard than statutory
nuisance which is environmental health
so
i would hope that in the reality that
noise should be less of an impact
on neighbours from this proposal and if
there was any breaches
we would be able to regularize that and
resolve them
but as councillor thompson said in
relation
to that just because somebody may or may
not and i'm not going to comment one way
out about this app because it's a
general point
if someone does or does not have a
history of
doing what they should do for one of
their better phrase whether it's
planning legislation or
building weeks or whatever that's not
material consideration for the
determination the application you have
to treat everybody
as though they are reasonable so with
those in mind i think
um that recommendation covers most of
the points that
the public have raised and actually will
hopefully touch would make actually
a better situation and then could be if
worst case scenario as
is thank you chairman uh thank you
actually
i i've realized i haven't in fact put
the recommendation so i'm going to put
the recommendation that it be approved
could i have a
seconder just for the sake of debate
please
somebody anybody oh there our second
john cage okay thank you councillor
please julie seconded
uh i do have one more question for you
mr lee though
i can see councillor white would like to
speak the business of the storage of
refuse and
waste who determines what
is acceptable and is what is done now
automatically acceptable
was that a question for environmental
health
um through chairman just because it's
done now doesn't mean it will
automatically be acceptable no
um to certainly obviously we
are you could argue that we will have to
be a bit more lenient
than if it was a brand new development
but i don't
think that planning would consider if
what's happening is happening
um and it's happening consul et cetera
that would be an appropriate method so
that would
we would still look at what is expected
to protect the amenity of neighbours etc
and we would work with environmental
health to make sure that it
was a robust uh method of uh
dealing with the waste thank you
chairman okay thank you right miss white
i'm sorry
to have kept you
that's okay thank you i mean i i'm sort
of sitting on the fence this one i do
have some concerns um
the application isn't clear and i can't
get into my council emails
because i if i get off the screen i
can't get back into it
and but if i'm right it looks like he's
demolishing one building to replace that
with two log cabins
and then the other thing is to put next
quite a large extension
on another building and now i want to
know is
how close are all of these to the
neighboring properties because it looks
like it's got houses all the way around
and um i i have to say i am concerned
that environmental health have concerns
over the application
and the final thing is on disposing of
the waste
and bearing in mind it is a residential
location um they mentioned they've got a
tank which i presume
is like an inceptor i don't know if it
is or not but
what happens to the solids because i
wouldn't imagine you could flush all of
it
down the inceptor um and i don't i'm not
really too bothered whether it's the new
application or an old one i think
if it's approved the the conditions need
to be absolutely
top-notch to protect the residents now i
haven't decided which way i'm going to
vote yet on this one because i i
i i've got equal sympathy with both the
applicant and the neighbors
um so i want to be absolutely certain
before i decide what is happening with
all of the waste and i think this is
very very important
and there should be some really
stringent conditions
attached but if i could have a look at
the buildings that are there and then a
block plan
showing the bits that are being
demolished and the bits are being
extended
so unfortunately i can't get to the
other ones so there's a few questions
there yes please i think all members
might appreciate that thank you
um i think they're on the same
footprints more or less
can i give you an answer to councillor
white in terms of waste and in terms of
my understanding
from what i'm getting for by residents
yes please do but if miss parker haynes
could get the required drawings up
while you do that that would be helpful
okay
thank you chairman so at the moment my
understanding from the residents who are
next to the property
is the solid wastes are put into an open
skip currently
which is at the front of the property
hence why there's a problem with
odor and flies currently
quite yes i do know they are using the
skip
i believe it's bagged up um
and that was the reason for my question
to mr lee
of whether what is currently happening
is automatically acceptable because in
my view that is not acceptable
it just isn't um
so what else if anything else is going
down a drone or into a tank i don't know
but certainly if we do agree to approve
this um i'm going to check with mr lee
that we
absolutely have these conditions as
tight as we can
right sorry as for boundaries perhaps ms
parker haynes you could point out
if the if they are in fact more or less
on the same footprint or if anything is
nearer to other people's other
boundaries than has been
thank you chairman so the proposed log
cabin
is actually located north point nor one
meter further from the shared boundary
with the chalet and
one and
what's that in old money tiny yeah but
at any rate not near it okay
yeah and obviously it's an increase
in depth um to the southern boundary
with saffron cottage
and but this is minor
okay thank you
uh sorry councillor wipe your hands up
again yes um
another question thank you yeah it's
just to double check
where the sewage goes because presumably
if it's licensed i would have expected
all this to have been
submitted with the application because i
think waste and the inceptor tank is
absolutely vital
and my thoughts are if we don't have all
of this that it should be deferred
until we do have the relevant
information because it's it's
you know i i feel for the neighbours and
i want to make the best decision i can
and i am concerned that this isn't
overly clear on what's happening to the
waste
um i think you're absolutely right with
your concern
for the neighbours um i'd like to think
we can make sure
that this is done by condition rather
than
having to wait and see because what does
happen is less important to me than what
happens in the future which
i'm about to ask mr lee if we can tie
down so mr lee
thank you chairman um i think you know
as i've already said you know this
use is lawful and to a certain extent
how they what they do with the waste now
is not a material consideration
determination of this
application um whether it's appropriate
or not
it's a different matter but it's not a
discussion for the planning committee
it's not material consideration for this
application
as i've said you know i think about the
number i can't which
uh condition six i think it was states
that you know
stories of rescues and waste shall be
provided in
full writing by the locals so it should
catch all
right okay can i i'd actually want to
get that probably slightly amended the
wording
uh right writing to the local author it
should be
um the details as approved shall be
fully implemented prior to the
first use of the development here by
committee to retain such thereafter
um the condition's fine but it could be
made a little bit
clearer maybe but um so okay well
if if we agree this we'll put it with
the change
i would suggest that the existing
situation
you know anecdotally um
isn't great but that isn't the
consideration for the termination this
application thank you chairman
okay thank you because determining the
example the
um not determining it not approving it
doesn't stop what happens now
okay right members i don't have any more
hands up
so i think we should
oh could we have our screen back please
mrs parket
thank you for that apology of course no
absolutely fine
i think we should vote then
please members um katie could you take a
roll call
yes chairman so we are going to hear me
hello yes i can hear someone
uh it's mr johnson but i'm going to
hello
sorry johnson yeah now so i just wanted
to just get in quickly before you went
to the vote
um i've just had a a look at the case
file
um to try and ascertain some indication
of what the
the applicant might be considering in
terms of
the uh waste and refuge condition
um and what i suppose what has given
officers some support
in that condition is that they're stated
and this is in response particularly to
the
concerns raised by local residents that
um
um they said that they they they have a
contract starting early next year it's
planned for specialist waste collection
the skip is currently being replaced
with two large lidded bins that will be
emptied either weekly or fortnightly
then depending on how full they are now
based around that that will give us some
indication of the sort of detail we
could look at and that we could work
with
to see whether that would be appropriate
and also in consultation with our
environmental health
so if that gives any sort of assistance
in
the direction within which we'd be
looking at details for the conditions
okay thank you mr johnson right mr lee
please come back
sorry chairman i've just actually reread
the condition and actually you know
it is fine it was me just stumbling over
it when i was reading it out loud and
trying to process the words that were
going through my brain at the same time
sorry about that now the condition is
fine yet
i missed one of the words when i was
reading it thanks
okay oh mr just took her hand down so i
think you might have just answered the
question
or not can't hear you sorry i was just
going to say that that basically i think
if we can beef up the conditions and
make them really
really stringent it would actually be um
a benefit of the neighbours it would be
better than what's there but it is on a
caveat the conditions are really really
strong
oh okay um as mr lee says we can only do
what we can do but um
mr lee is there any or mr johnson are
there any
options in there the condition
at the moment asked for details to be
submitted um
not really anywhere beefing that up to
use cancer white's phrase because
it's not asking for anything per se it's
just asking for details for us
to consider um and without any
best practice or anything like that i
wouldn't want to be putting
anything like that into the condition
but that would be stuff we would
consider normally
when proceed when dealing with the
condition anyway
okay thank you i mean i suppose i
suppose the only thing i would sort of
add to that is is possibly
um um
just look at the condition where's the
details on instant stories and refusing
waste
i mean we could um there can be some
some leading elements within the
conditions of some of the direction
where we're going like
location so for example the location may
be an issue
yeah which is something that as part of
developing the conditions we can
consider whether that's appropriate or
not
obviously again that's something that we
would work up with with the applicant
but if that can give members some sort
of um
confidence in terms of the direction
that would be looking to any discharge
of conditions
i mean there's been an indication in
terms of the type of covering and
enclosure but i suppose also the
location
is something that can be a consideration
right well they're looking at the plan i
think that's quite limited but um
yes as long as that's added to the
wording
i'm certainly prepared to carry on with
the recommendation as it is with that
amendment
okay i'm hoping counselor keys who
seconded it will agree
yes would you like so would it be thank
you
details in relation to the storage of
refuse and waste including locations
shall be submit
shall be provided and approved in
writing by the local plan authority
collections and things you know that
they offered make sure that's in there
too
yeah feature obviously i think i've seen
details in relation to storage and rev
is that's all of what we would be
looking at um and i think
we i wouldn't want to get into a point
where we listed off too many bullet
points because then
there could be bits that we would want
that we haven't stated that could be
other than you haven't
absolutely absolutely certainly is it
our office i'm certain our officers have
got the message about
how keen we are i think if it's gonna
happen
if it's gonna happen we haven't voted
yet but if it's gonna happen it's got to
be
right i mean okay yeah
a little bit difficult because that may
depend on the contract
quite okay um thank you i think we'll
have a vote now katie
and we are voting as katie will probably
say anyway in a minute
on the recommendation to approve
thank you chairman so we are voting to
approve the application
as per the officer's report members i
will take your name in alphabetical
order
if you could tell me for against or
abstain please
counselor mrs fleming against
katie thank you councillor jarvis
thank you councillor keys
for coyote thank you councillor
against thank you councillor mrs
thompson
four thank you councillor miss white
for because i think the conditions will
improve what the residents
currently have to live next to thank you
thank you okay thank you katie how does
that stack up
that's four four and two against no
abstentions
okay thank you well um
that is passed in accordance with the
officer's
recommendation and report thank you uh
right we need to get
mr morley put the councillor morley back
in can we
do that or should i text him
we should be able to call him in
i'm not sure if there's an official way
of doing this but anyway
he's back here he's back he's back he's
back
excellent thank
that's probably me okay
okay right everyone's back right we've
got to start moving a bit faster now i'm
afraid members so
we have item seven on our agenda our
third planning application which is land
rear of hillbarn rectory lane wood and
water
um so we have ms bowles
to present the report and then two
submissions
one from an objector and one from the
agent okay so
ms bowles please thank you chair
so planning permission is sought for the
conversion of existing
equestrian and storage buildings to form
offices with associated access parking
and landscaping
we've got the block plan and this is a
subject building just here
sorry that was a location plan this is
the block plan
you can see the parking area and an area
of hard standing to the front of the
building
there's some new tree screens proposed
in the air
i can't see much of anything is there
any possibility of zooming oh that's
that's better thank you
we've got the existing elevations
and the proposed elevations the physical
changes
um relate to the changing of the metal
roof sheeting
with plane tiles and new and upgraded
window and door openings
you've got the existing floor plan
and the proposed floor plan the
footprint of the building
will remain as existing
and then we've got some site photographs
having taken all the material planning
considerations into account it's not
considered that the development would be
acceptable in principle
the proposal fails to meet all of the
criteria contained within policy
four of the ldp given given the
inadequate information to support the
justifiable and functional need
the harmful visual impact resulting from
the urbanization of the existing rural
site and countryside has not been
adequately justified and would not be
offset by
any by the benefits in this instance
therefore the application is recommended
for refusal
thank you chair thank you
right so we have our two public
participants so we have
mr goff who's an object mr golf can we
get you
up and running
hello hello right if you're able to
speak please use your video if
that's possible if it isn't that that's
fine too we'll have to live with that
um you have two minutes from
when you begin to speak so when you're
ready thank you
thank you chairman members my name is
stephen goff
i live with my family at hill place
rectory lane which is our family home
and one of the closest properties to the
development proposed by this application
we we believe these proposals are
contrary to the policies in your adopted
local plan
the location of this site is remote well
outside the boundary of any recognized
settlement
this is in no sense a sustainable
location for this type of development
every journey associated with the
proposed office will have necessity be
made by motor vehicle
which again is not sustainable this will
allow
traffic to a quiet unlit singletrack
lane with no passing places to the
detriment of existing residents
pedestrians cyclists
and horse riders who regularly use
rectory lane this proposed office
development by virtue of its urbanizing
characteristics will appear intrusive
in this tranquil rural landscape so the
considerable detriment of those like
ourselves who live here
and those who frequently walk along the
retreat
lane and the public footpaths from which
the proposed development is prominently
visible
it is clear that there may be benefits
to the creation of employment in this
case yet this application
tells us relatively little about the use
proposed
or about any functional need or other
justification for this development in
this location
as is required by your local plan
policies
any such clean benefit will of course be
extremely limited
and more than outweighed by the very
substantial harm which will result if
this application is approved
we support the conclusions of your
officers and strongly urge members to
vote this evening with officers
recommendation
and refuse planning permission thank you
very much for listening
thank you mr golf uh and now we have mr
matthew wood who is the agent um again
can we get you online
good evening uh good evening right you
have two minutes from when you begin to
speak
thank you off you go very much
good evening to members as officers have
highlighted the applicant seeks full
planning permission for the conversion
of the
existing commercial barn into office use
the external appearance of the building
will remain to reflect its traditional
appearance
and rural location aesthetically it is
proposed to utilize
as many existing openings as possible
for windows and doors
with the addition of new openings to
allow for better natural daylight into
the building
the size scale and height of the
building will remain the same
the applicants submitted and paid for
pre-op for a pre-application
meeting with officers to discuss the
design and appearance
however no meeting or response was ever
produced
uh despite repeated chasing for this
the applicant has recently planted new
hedgerow along the northern boundary
consisting of 17 new hedge plants
and 10 new established trees consisting
of silver birch
and field maple the additional planting
will also result
in net gains in biodiversity thereby
improving the
environmental quality of the sites it is
submitted that all existing and new
vegetation along the boundaries of the
sites provide appropriate natural
screening
the boundaries will therefore provide
substantial containment and concealment
of the site
and reduce the prominence of any built
form outside its immediate boundaries
it is also submitted that the proposed
development would not be harmful to the
character and appearance of the
landscape or local countryside
will result in urbanisation the
provision and change of use of the
building will also help to support
and enhance the vitality and viability
of existing local services
and facilities and provide local
employment needs as strongly supported
by the mppf
the applicant also wishes to inform
members that they already have two
companies seriously interested
in using these offices the application
was
formally consulted on with all statutory
consultees confirming that they have no
objection to the proposals
with officers also confirming the
acceptability of the proposals
in relation to neighbouring immunity
considerations
um right
first job is to put the recommendation
which is for refusal on the table
um will somebody second that please
all right councillor jarvis was first um
right councillor durham didn't in fact
call this
in but we're aware he had to go away
we'd have been going some to get this
to this point by seven o'clock anyway
although i wish we had
um so councillor jarvis you're the other
board member um
i hope you are you able to give us
councillor durham's point of view as
well as your own sorry
i i candy i think counselor durham's
point of view was purely with reference
to the employment
point uh i think that is noted on the
paperwork
um uh i can't really comment more on
uh than that that was that was why he
called it in
um from my own point of view uh i could
only echo
the eloquent words uh of of mr golf that
you just heard
i mean i've looked at the application i
think the officers have got this one
right
and i think the reasons for refusal
stand um
you know this is a quiet country lane
and uh
this uh this really would be a
a significant uh urbanization of the
site if it was used for offices
the amount of car trips that would then
go up and down that lane
would change the very nature of what's
currently uh in place so
that's all i say at the moment chairman
i think uh i'll listen to other councils
i'm happy to say thank you councillor
white
please
thank you mom and chairman i mean i've
looked at this and
like every application i determine them
on their merits
and i actually disagree with the
officers and i think the benefits
outweigh the harm
um for me it's an important employment
site
it's only light office use and we
definitely need employment
we desperately need business rates and
that absolutely accords with our local
development plan
and unlike the previous application
there will actually be an
improvement in the air quality and
pollution and
nuisance because there'll be no manure
smells no noise no horses kicking doors
at two o'clock in the morning
i actually think there'll be less
traffic than stables and it won't be
anti-social hours because obviously
every nose with horses you have to be
there day and night
and i actually think there will be um an
improvement on the effect on the
countryside and i think i think it'll
actually help the neighbors because
there'll be more screening than there
currently is
and they're going to replace was it a
tin roof with
tiles and there's no change the absolute
building so
i think that the benefits far outweigh
the harm and i think this does a call
with our local development plan
and i'm sorry i come to a completely
contrary um
decision to the applicants uh took away
to the offices
okay thank you our counselor siddal
oh sorry it counts for the keys i should
put counselor keys in first you'll hire
on my list
apologies counselor siddle counselor
keys please
that's not a problem counselor could
have gone first if he requires but i've
um have we got the hours
can we put a stipulation on ours or is
there an hour stipulation
in their present i couldn't see one is
it
seven till four or seven or five five
i'm sure we could if we ended up
approving it but as it's
for a refusal that that's that kind of
thing is just isn't addressed here but
we
we would if we got to that we could if
we needed to
i'd say all right okay
thank you um so councillor siddal please
then
thank you chairman uh i am on
the in agreement with the officers this
is an inappropriate location
for a business site uh it's not the
right place to develop something like
this
and the officers have got this right and
i agree with the recommendation
thank you um uh councillor morley i've
got you
next on my list yeah thank you chairman
i just wanted to see is a map we could
see of the
um access into the site please
again
no
obviously not okay it was just
access um do we have any details on
on the access please response
yeah for your channel
i've lost you
i can look on my mat don't worry okay
okay thank you do come back if you need
more information all right councillor
fleming oh here we go
it's there now there you go okay
got it thank you uh right i've got
councillor
fleming but i do have a quick question
um i can't find it and just for clarity
is is this to replace all the equestrian
use or only some of it
will it be mixed that's a question for
the characters
i think please yeah okay and it will be
just an office use okay thank you sorry
councillor fleming um
off you go please
councillor fleming you're on mute jane
sorry i just wanted to say that i think
the officers on balance have this right
uh i know rectory lane it's a very quiet
that's
particular spot is very rural very
inaccessible so i think they have this
right thank you
thank you um i must admit i'm somewhat
concerned myself you know
you have to fill all the fulfill all the
policies not just
some of them at least that's the theory
um and i think it's possible this will
come back with more
information but for now i'm certainly
not happy to approve it so
i have no more hands i have put the
recommendation julie seconded that this
should be refused for the reasons
as detailed so katie could you please
take a vote
uh yes chairman so we are voting to
refuse the application as per the
officer's
recommendation take your name in
alphabetical order
starting with counselor mrs fleming
for thank you
councillor jarvis
thank you council of keys
four thank you councillor morley
four thank you councillor
four thank you councillor mrs thompson
four thank you and councillor miss white
again chairman that is six
four and one against okay thank you
thank you members um so that is refused
in line with the officer's
recommendation
so we now have eight on our agenda the
next planning application is for saturn
7-0 colchester road break tottenham
so miss bolles could we have the report
please
i believe there are no further speakers
no that public speakers okay
so report please
thank you chair the planning permission
is sought for the construction of a new
dwelling
we've got the location plan
and the block plan which shows the
proposed wedding
parking area and amenity space to the
rear
the proposed elevations
and the proposed floor and roof plans
and we have some site photos
and please note the caravan is no longer
on the site
and this application is a resubmission
following the refusal of a previous
scheme
the reason for refusal related solely to
the detrimental visual impact
the appearance of the proposed dwelling
mainly caused by the
administration scheme across the front
elevation
would have caused the amendments to the
scheme are considered to have overcome
the previous reason for refusal
in 2013 the application site was
considered to be a sustainable location
for residential development
given that there have been no
significant changes to the site or
surrounding area that would alter the
stance previously taken
no objections to the principle of the
development are raised
it's considered that the proposal would
have an acceptable visual impact
on the site and character and appearance
of the area and no objections are raised
to the impact of the development on
residential amenity
car parking provision or amenity space
therefore the application is recommended
for approval
thank you thank you thank you very much
um i'll take it this is tottenham ward
is it councillor siddal
councillor keys yeah
[Music]
right um yeah i was trying to work out
exactly where it was
um since i've got you councillor civil
would you be happy to start us off
uh yes i i'm happy to go along with the
officer's recommendation in terms of
this application
uh it makes sense in terms of its
location and as the officer says
it doesn't have any impact and the new
design
is a great improvement on the previous
one so
yeah as the board member i'm happy to go
with the officer's recommendation
[Music]
oh that's that's simple counselor
um yes i i don't have a problem i know
where it is it was
just where was the access going to be
was it going to be down that little
zillow like an auxiliary road down the
side or
i can't remember how the access was
going to be to it that was all
it's off that old road is really with
the older ones
yeah that's it i can see yeah that's
fine
all right okay thank you thank you
uh so the recommendation
is to um oh is to approve
i haven't heard anyone speak against it
so could we
have the wrong call please should we
divide our sent german
well we can but it's just a bit awkward
if anyone doesn't yeah i hear what
you're saying and in the chamber it
would be so easy because everyone's hand
goes up at once
um so katie could we gallop through the
roll call please
um yes chairman so we are voting to
um approve the application as per the
officer's recommendation
counselor fleming please
[Music]
[Music]
four coating thank you
councillor morley
thank you councillor
four thank you
councillor mrs thompson four thank you
thank you councillor miss white
[Music]
oh okay thank you
chairman that was seven four and thank
you okay thank you everyone um so that
is
approved in line with the office's
report so we're moving a little faster
now
item number nine or our agenda is barnes
and jason
i'm also again you're off again okay
we'll have you back in afterwards thank
you thank you councilman
uh barnes adjacent to muskling's farm
chelsea road pearly um okay let's parker
haynes please
thank you chairman planning permission
is sought for the retention of the
existing dwelling house
it should be noted that this dwelling
house was permitted under the terms of
the prior approval
application 1501096
which allowed the change of use of two
bonds from agricultural to residential
however as set out in section 5.3 of the
officer report
these works were not completed within
the time frame or in accordance with the
plans as approved
and therefore the use of this barn as a
dwelling house is currently unlawful and
does not benefit from formal consent
this is the location plan it should be
united that this application relates
solely to the completed and occupied
single-story dwelling to the east and
includes the provision of a private
footpath
through the fields to the south to join
the formalized footpath
on chelmsford road this is the block
plan these are the floor plans and
elevations of the dwelling
these are the elevations of the approved
prior approval application
the alterations relate to the
positioning of windows and doors this is
explained further in section 3.2.2 of
the officer's report
and here are some photographs of the
site it should be noted that the site
does not benefit from formal consent and
therefore there is no fallback position
established by the expired prior
approval application
this matter is thoroughly explained in
section 5.1 of the officer's report
furthermore an application to regularize
the development including the bond to
the west
was refused planning permission by the
northwestern planning committee on the
8th of june 2020
this application is recommended for
refusal it is not considered that the
provision of a dwelling would be
acceptable on this site due to the
location
and design of the dwelling and the
detrimental impact this would have on
the character and appearance of the site
and surrounding countryside
through the inherent domestication of
the site thank you chairman
thank you uh right we have no one to
speak on this no member of the public uh
the recommendation is that the
application should be refused and anyone
prepared to second that
i'll second it and only until we have
the debate
and i would like yeah that's absolutely
absolutely fine um
i i know people think it's strange that
you can proposal second a thing and then
vote against it but
you can uh councillor fleming
was this one you were going to speak on
or
not i noticed you called it in so if
you're going to speak please do
yes please chair and could i just ask
hayley to bring up
the location plan from her presentation
thanks holly um so the first point i'd
like to make about the
officer's comment set in the conclusion
3.3.1
um i might have agreed with their
comments
maybe five ten years ago but living
locally i know this road really well
um so i know that the sort of
character of the area has changed
significantly
over the last five years as because of
developments across the road if you can
see if everyone can see
rudely oaks um tree lawn nursery
thai meadows and brook house have all
been granted at appeal
um i think from memories maybe in 2016
2019 um
basically the planning inspector
disagreed and said that this
the location was sustainable and that
you know it didn't have a detrimental
impact on the area
so for that reason um yeah i have
concerns about the officer's
recommendation also talking about pearly
it is um you know the applicants have
put in
a permissive path which sort of takes
you up to
a stretch of footpath so it is walkable
now to
services pearly has an
outstanding primary school nursery
there's a pub there's an award-winning
community shop
that's open seven days a week and they
deliver
um so yeah i think that the officers
probably have it wrong on this one thank
you
thank you uh councillor white i have you
top of my list
[Music]
yeah thank you madam chairman um i mean
as i've said before i
judge every application that comes
before me on its merits on the evening
it comes before and
i objected to this one the last section
before us because the garden
didn't comply with the garden size
regulations at the time and they've
obviously addressed that because that
isn't a reason anymore
and um in relation to the other
applications that my fellow ward member
mentions
further around the corner sunny cot also
got approved at appeal
and as did an application between what
used to be the queen's head and gardens
cottages i don't know what it's called
now just by spa lane there so lots of
been through to say it's sustainable
like the first application today i
thought that was
had no issues with it i have absolutely
no issues with this one and i'd like to
propose that we
approve this application um as i think
the
benefit outweighs the harm it will help
with our five-year land supply
and it now complies with the garden size
which i had a problem with last time
um so i've got no problems with it this
time and as i say i make my decision
every time i objected last time
i'm more in mind to approve this time
because it's a different
they've made changes that i i i agree
with
okay thank you and councillor keys is my
last speaker at the moment
[Music]
um am i correct i said it's just the
planning has
lapsed was that what i heard
yes mr
um please there's a couple of points of
like to come back and deal with it as a
whole um
as um as park hanes explained in
when during the presentation this
application
or a subject half this application was
half of the planning application that
relatively recently the north west
planning committee
refused on location on
sustainability and as always i was
highlight that you know
the starting point for termination
application must be the development plan
unless material considerations indicate
otherwise and as always
i'll echo that planning history on the
site is a material consideration of
significant weight
um obviously the immunity space has
changed
um in relation to the
access to the site the proposal now
includes a
footpath uh on their own land for one of
a better phrase
to try and access pearly obviously this
would be
down a totally dark unlit area which
obviously is something that
officers as we don't support and
something that
um has something you know an approach
that wouldn't i would think very
unlikely to be supported appeal because
you know it would not be a something
that is likely to be
embraced by a future occupier
particularly at times of inclement
weather or darkness
um in relation to
um councillor keys point it's not that
planning permission has lapsed
what they got was a prior approval
process which doesn't look
into things like sustainability and
access to facilities and everything
that permission was granted in 2015 and
needed to be undertaken by 2018
to be able to be implemented and to be
usable
that has fallen away uh nearly three
years ago now
so that permission isn't the case they
got planning permission and now that
that's expired it was a totally
different permission through
a different set of considerations and
planning
policies for one of a better phrase so
it's a bit of a moot point to a certain
extent but
i think as ms parker haynes explained
that is
very very robustly and detailed assessed
within the office report and i won't
repeat that now
thank you um
counselor keys did you have someone to
say your hand
is that oh
wait it did but i didn't finish well you
know um as i've come back on
i've just heard uh no street lights well
i've managed to get about my place for
i'll tell you how old i am now 48 years
of a torch we live in the countryside we
don't want street lights you know i've
had this on many occasions
so yeah i'm sorry but i don't think i
agree with that
and also i was second mrs white's
proposal
okay well we haven't got there yet
because we have a recommendation on the
table right the next person i've got who
hasn't spoken is councillor siddal and
and then i will give you other two a
second goku especially your ward members
thank you chairman uh yeah i would just
uh like to back up what council jesus
just said if i look out on my
window now uh it is pitch black and i
have no street lights
but i can quite happily live here and
cope with living here
with no street lights and no pavement so
you know people are
not able to do that
okay once again
can i just once again echo members can
be very conscious of what is said
and the reasoning behind government and
planning permission because
statements like that are basically
saying that we are we can allow housing
anywhere in the district
um and it's contrary to appeal decisions
conscious to government guidance
concentrating ppf
but you know lots of these statements
that being made are made going to be
making it very hard for officers to
resist development through the district
that's all i'd like to say
because these will be used against us
they absolutely will um i mean i live in
the middle of nowhere with no footpath
and no lighting and
it was a replacement dwelling there's no
way we'd get a permission for a new one
here now
uh or even would have 60 odd years ago
um right i have councillor
white and councillor fleming want to
come back councillor white's higher up
my list
so you go first please yeah thank you
madam chairman
i mean it's just to say that actually
the reason i refer i was one of the
members who refused it last time and the
reason i refused it was the amenities
space
and that's been addressed and we also
now do not have a five-year land supply
which we did have the last time the
application
came behind us and i i think that it
would be
absolutely ridiculous to have a fully
converted building that people are
living in and then removing it when we
don't have a five-year land supply and i
honestly think
that the benefits outweigh the harm yet
again
and and it's not i say i refuse it last
time but this time i approve it because
the application has changed and i'm
deciding it on
its merits thank you
counselor mr council fleming thank you
chad i just
wanted to point out to committee members
that this is actually a working farm
and the application is from the farmers
it's for their family it's a livestock
farm
so it's it's housing the family so it's
not in conflict with the nppf
in fact i think that it uh it's fully
compliant with paragraph 78
to promote sustainable development in
rural areas housing should be located
where it will enhance
and maintain the vitality of rural
communities
they work in the community it's
moscone's farm is one of the last
dairy farms in essex so i think
that to approve this application would
be totally in line with policy
it is in a sustainable accessible
location
um and because of the
developments allowed on appeal
you know in very close proximity um i
feel that it does comply with policy
thank you
okay thank you uh right i ran out of
hands so i think we'd better vote
oh no council councilor lee dear oh
deary deary me mr lee please
thank you chairman um just a couple of
points on sort of some of the
points that have been in debates
obviously if this is grantors you will
need a reason for approval so just
comment on a couple of points firstly
the fact that
the prop application is for
people that live in the village you know
using the village you know his family
etc
is something that's been found to be an
illegal reason for granting planning
permission
previously um it's not planning sits
with the land it is not about who the
applicant is or
how they personally um
might use the site or relate to the site
because that is
not the material consideration and has
been found to be in a you know to be
honest
a cult council committee was uh very
heavily
uh reprimanded i'll leave it at that for
actually doing those exact decisions so
i'll flag members that would be very
conscious wording what they use
secondly um my advice would be if
if this applicant is suggesting which
they haven't that this is
a dwelling that is particularly needed
for the viability of the business it
should be submitted as an agricultural
workers dwelling
not as an independent dwelling that in
theory could be sold and could be
occupied totally
separate to an existing farm so for that
that would be one of the reasons why you
we wouldn't be able to give
some of the points to council flame was
really any weight in my advice when
coming to a decision
um and i can't remember what the third
point was i'll just
type the word nothing so it's not really
going to help me in coming back on the
point so
um but it's actually it has i've jogged
my mind well what i'd say is that you
know members need to be very conscious
of the previous appeal decision
i mean not people's decision by the
committee and i do acknowledge
councillor white's point
about immunity space but the application
was determined by the council on the
all of the reasons refusal not on just
one so
although one of them may well have
fallen away do not consider that
the the one in relation to
sustainability and location has i just
think
members need to be very conscious that
when coming to determination of this
application
thank you chairman
councillor fleming is that a new hand or
a legacy hand
new hand yes i just wanted to
ask um mr lee about
um the appeals history across the road
um whether i'm correct in thinking that
that is a material consideration
the fact that the inspector uh i think
there's about five properties across the
road where the inspector has said that
there's no harm to the royal character
that the character had changed over time
and the fact that they were sustainable
locations is that a material
consideration for us mr lee
um thank you chairman an appeal decision
would be but what i would highlight is
that
they were still material considerations
of the termination of the last
application
so that was the most recent application
would carry more weight
in my advice to members than previous
appeal decisions
and that section or there's a section
within the office report in 5.7.5 which
deals with that matter
and highlights the differences between
the um
ex previous permissions and the current
submission um thank you chairman
thank you okay well we do have the
officer's recommendation to refuse to
put first so
we'll do that but i i must admit that
approving this looks to me like an open
invitation to have
people get whatever kind of permission
um
let it run out then build something that
wasn't on the plan and then
get it agreed later um i'm sorry
one other point sorry to attend is that
just in
relation to if this is approved
obviously part of the debate one of the
issues that was raised this is an
existing building being used for
habitable permission
i would advise that members do not give
any way to develop without plan of
mission being occupied as a material
consideration because
that would then in theory encourage
people to convert buildings without
planning permission into residential
accommodation
and then argue that the council
considers that because we have no
five-year land supply and inappropriate
it wouldn't be appropriate to remove
that residential use
because obviously that was sort of basic
summary of what the wording is obviously
if this is approved
i just advise them to be very very
careful of the wording
for why it's being approved while the
recommendation is not being
agreed because it's actually being lived
in without permission
because without anything encouraging
theory in my opinion anybody
to do it yep thank you right all right
council miss white right
very very quick and then we're gonna go
thank you just just briefly
just to say the application has changed
it is different to the previous
application
and the layout and some of the other
items are different therefore
i have come to a different view this
time that is
and that is what i can do as a member
and i i'm finding it very strange that
i have to make the same decision every
time on balance
because they've changed the issues i had
a problem with and
and there have been lots of appeal lots
and lots of appeal approvals along that
road it's not one
that they said there's there's lots and
lots of them that is why i don't have a
problem the inspector says it's a
sustainable location
i think it's the same location and
they've sorted out the garden space and
and i've come to a different decision
because it's a different application
thank you
okay thank you right i'm going to put
the recommendation katie please quick
super quick roll call so we're
voting on sorry first of
to refuse the application as per the
officer's recommendation
counselor mrs fleming against
thank you councillor jarvis
councillor jarvis
apologist chairman i was on mute against
okay the keys against
thank you councillor against
thank you councillor mrs thompson for
miss white against
thank you chairman that is four i'm
sorry one four
and five against okay thank you so now i
need a
proposal uh presumably to approve
uh with reasons that a address the
reasons for refusal
in the report and b please don't say
someone's already living
okay so who's going to give me that
proposal do you want me to go
check sure
taking the officer's wording we could
say
it is considered that the provision of a
dwelling would be acceptable on the site
um and the location design of the
proposed
dwelling would not have a detrimental
impact
um on the character and appearance of
the surrounding countryside
is that good enough
i'm not the planner um
um obviously it's not normally
acceptable just to
uh just obviously try and basically say
whatever the officer said is
was the harm isn't not the harm
particularly taken into account with
this one there
was a previous decision by this
committee that said the location wasn't
acceptable for a dwelling
and that's my biggest you know i do try
to help members as much as i can
but it's very difficult when the council
has made the decision
that he's totally contrary to
or you know previous decision is
consistent with the recommendation when
that recommendation is gone against
it's very difficult for me to provide
members advice and help
as to why you can go against our
recommendation i do try to assist
members but
you know we need to as a decision maker
evidence what has materially altered
between
this and the previous decision and one
of the concerns of his refusal was
location
i acknowledged councillor white's point
about the
certain aspects have changed such a
meaningless but that reason fools was
falling away
the fact that this has been determined
by the council
by this committee even relatively
recently
that it was an inappropriate location
means there really needs to be something
aimed at that that he's put forward as
part of the reason for approval thank
you chairman
thank you okay balls in your court
council fleming
so how about the development
um would make a positive contribution in
terms of social economic
sustainability um and is acceptable
in content in the context of national
and local planning policies
um particularly in relation to the fact
that this is a
different application uh there's now a
footpath
um which means that the footway
uh sparling can now be accessed so the
site is accessible
mr lee okay um
i wouldn't i don't think we could go as
far as saying it was compliant with
policy and national guidance
but if members consider that that
footpath now means that it's a uh
becomes an acceptable and sustainable
location then obviously that's within
their gift to do so the
i can just see a lot of footpaths in
darkness being put forward
um and yeah you know this is the
difficult position you know every
applicant has a right to be treated
exactly the same so every decision we
make as a committee which chips away at
our policies of our
requirements for like previously i know
we agree members agreed the previous
application but that's an example where
there's like five criteria in that
employment policy and
certain ones were not met you know if we
start to say that they don't matter
every applicant has a right not to
submit that information and
you know decisions like this if this is
granted we're going to say
footpaths that have no lie
no safe use and i know members are
saying that they live like that but that
is not what the policies require that is
not what
a government guidance expects so you
know we will make
decisions difficult for officers and i
think we'll start
you know that's just where we are thank
you matt could we say then
um that the development wouldn't have
just
a detrimental impact on the character
and appearance of the surrounding
countryside
um through chairman it's a very
difficult situation because
we've only recently said that there
wasn't
this it was only performing six months
ago and you've really got to talk about
what the difference is i know councillor
white's highlighted the lack of a
five-year land supply and obviously
that is a difference and so
automatically being outside
the uh um
the fact that it's automatically outside
the uh
settlement boundary outside the segment
boundary is no longer a reason for
refusal
um what
you know obviously if members don't
consider on balance that the provision
of
this footpath has made the site
acceptable
um you know i know key towards the fact
that there was a previous permission
so that is a you know of material
consideration of some weight and on
balance overall you know it has made it
materially different to previous
application taking at the various points
of debate you know that would have some
merit but
a lot of the what you've got i'd be
advising members is to
look at the differences between the
previous permission and this because
and saying why they've overcome
the reasons that go to the core because
a lot of the other points
there's no real difference and you we
can't we can't
as in legally we cannot just say oh we
said this five
minutes ago we don't agree with it now
and that's not that's just
point of law you know just goodbyes
members we we can't be done next if
anyone did choose to jr one of our
decisions we would lose so
my advice is to members to look at the
differences and as councillor
white said there is now no longer a
five-year land supply
and you know and if members think that
footpath as councillor key
said is acceptable then and if members
think that the fact that there was a
prior approval that's fallen away
um is their material consideration
that's within their gift thank you
chairman
there you go councillor fleming um
councilmembers
councillor white were you going to make
a suggestion or yeah i was always going
to suggest that we approve the
application
because on the balance of probability um
we the material consideration is we do
not now have a five year land supply so
that's a change since the last time the
application came before us
the applicants have addressed the um
issue regarding the immunity space
because the garden did not meet the
um required size and also we've had
recent appeal decisions that have
approved locations at
dwelling houses and found that the
location is sustainable along the main
road in purdy
harwood advisement didn't use the three
days
the last decision yeah yes i would
wouldn't advise members use that last
point because any recent appeal system
is okay that's fine well i i just think
then the the five-year land supply is a
material consideration and the
applicants have addressed the
garden space not meeting the malden ldp
housing guidelines or whatever they're
called okay
i'll second that are you all right with
that okay
then we need a vote please katie
of course thank you chairman um so we
are
voting to a approve the application
contrary to the officer's recommendation
um by the way sorry but
okay carry on uh councillor mrs fleming
four thank you katie thank you
councillor jarvis four
thank you keys
four thank you cody thank you
councillor four
thank you councillor mrs thompson
against sorry and councillor miss white
four thank you chairman that is five
four and one against
okay thank you um can we leave
conditions to be
delegated to officers and chairman and
ward members
i would recommend that your chairman
is that that's the correct approach is
it
mr lee okay so uh does everyone
does anyone disagree with that i'm not
sure what
conditions we'd impose so um i would
recommend the
you know rather than missing anything
especially taking into account it's
retrospective i wouldn't want to
recommend we put in any conditions that
aren't necessary either so
no just yeah okay no i'd far rather
we do that unless anyone violently
objects
or has anything to say oh mr lawrence i
just make the point chair
to you that there would be a section 106
agreement required to secure the
contribution
under the um habitat regulations yes
sorry i think the applicant's already
submitted that
there's parking trying to pick that up
yes sorry
i was just going to say they have
already submitted the union
unilateral undertaking so that's all
been checked and agreed so
that's okay perfect thank you um right
so uh we've agreed that we're going to
sort out the conditions between
me and particularly the
ward members although of course the
building's already there
right now item 10 the last one we have
oh can someone get councillor morley
back if he's coming
um we will be looking at
confirming or not a tree preservation
order on the pines franklin road north
cambridge
and it i know it's not going to be
sophie martin
but it is going to be hannah
right can we just hold off until we get
councillor morley back please just give
him a couple of minutes
um just out of interest katie how how do
we get someone back who's left
um we will click on him and part of the
attendees you can click on here and
invite him to join
he's being called at the moment
excellent
thank you sorry about the gap
but um you know we've already lost
councillor daram earlier so let's have
him
let's leave him back he's entitled to
his say
hello
thank you councillor right off we go tpo
thank you chair um yeah this item
relates to the confirmation of tpo
10-20 in july 2020 the council received
an inquiry from a customer who wanted to
fill
the lan sorry leilandai tree
which is situated within the front
garden of the pines as you can see here
due to the prominent location and size
it was considered that the removal of
the tree would materially impact the
immunity of the area
a tree evaluation method for
preservation orders was carried out and
the tree scored 15 out of 25
and concluded it was worthy of a true
preservation order
the resulting tpo was served on the 23rd
of july 2020.
one objection has been received from a
neighbouring occupier
the neighbor does not believe the
laylandia tree is worthy of a tpo due to
a number of reasons
including the poor condition of the tree
the life obstruction and the obstruction
of views from traffic
the neighbor highlights the debris from
the tree including
bird mess falls onto neighbouring lawn
driveways and cars and the power line
running through the tree
looks to be damaged by the growth and
movement
the objections from the neighbour have
not been resolved as the tree does not
appear to be in poor health
no evidence of damage to the power lines
has been provided
and the issue of falling debris and bird
mess is not considered to be a justified
reason for the removal of the tree
therefore the question of whether or not
to confirm the tpo
has been brought to the members to
decide um
here we've got the photos of the le
landai looking west
and looking east and due to its location
the size of the tree and the lack of
other substantial trees in the immediate
area
it is considered that the tree provides
significant immediate immunity value to
the character and appearance of the area
and the tpo
should be confirmed to prevent the
inappropriate works being carried out
which could harm the immunity value
and health of the tree thank you chair
okay well councillor white you heard
your hand up in a nano second
off you go thank you mr chairman um
could the officers tell me um what the
score on part b
was um on the tempo system because
part b says um you have to allow for
trees which are existing or near future
nuisance
including those clearly outgrowing their
contents
uh context or which are significantly
negating
the potential of other trees because
let's
make no mistake this isn't a field this
isn't a farm this isn't a track this is
somebody's front garden
and everybody knows that you can't get a
mortgage on a house
if they have a big lay landing tree
within 20 meters of their dwelling
because the roots grow under all the
houses
and particularly with the um ground
heave um that happens in northam bridge
and this is yeah it's a nice enough tree
but it's the lai landai it's just the in
absolutely the wrong location um i think
it's dangerous
um because if it does blow over which
lay land eyes do that is going to
flatten somebody's house either side of
the road
and i say i'm curious to see how the
officers have decided that it's um
not outgrowing their contents and it's
not either existing or a near future
nuisance because
that that is ridiculous plus you can see
lots of power cables and telephone
cables and goodness knows what else
and i'll say it's just a nice enough la
landai tree but it's the lay landai and
it is in
absolutely the wrong the wrong location
so
how did they give it a high enough score
on part b
dude chairman mine standing in school
was two but what i'd also like to
highlight
is the fact that you know it's not
it's very much a common practice to
serve tpos on properties um trees in
people's gardens you know i know
as a district we're probably much more
used to experience in them
in fields and hedgerows but as i can
guarantee from my experience
at previous authorities which much more
urban than malden
that it's a very common practice and
it's something that we
you know regularly able to defend an
appeal i'm sure mr johnson's experience
at london
except she would have still dealt with
tpos and still been in
quite urban areas so it's about
management it doesn't
automatically mean that it's
unacceptable thank you chairman
okay right i've got councillors next
thank you chairman uh i am
completely against the recommendation to
put a tpo on this
a la landai tree uh by
its nature has no benefit in terms of
the quality of that tree
they are dangerous trees
one of the things about them and the
reason why they do fall over so council
white is correct that they do fall over
they actually have very shallow roots
and that's why they fall over so easily
so therefore in terms of that particular
tree
and its location and its situation it's
in an absolutely
appalling place and therefore should
yeah my view is it should be removed
um because it's it's not it's not
benefiting the street in any way
landland i trees yeah people now avoid
them
because they are such a nuisance so in
terms of putting a tpo
on it i i totally disagree and yeah
i don't think it should happen
thank you um councilwoman i will go
through the
people who haven't spoken yet so
councillor jarvis is
next then councillors fleming
i just wanted
i mean we all know the land eye trees
are probably the worst value of tree
that there is
um they were very popular because they
grew quickly that's why people had them
but in terms of value of tree type of
tree um
this is you know not a native tree not
it's probably one of the least
attractive trees in terms of preserving
an individual tree no matter what size
this particular one i mean i'm amazed
that uh you know a tree that large
near those properties as we all know if
we're looking for any sort of
development
you you've got to have the tree a long
way away from the house
that is just in the wrong place and as
for the as for those
lines i'm sure if that was reported they
would come and want to trim that tree
because those lines those that those
electric lines get above
they shouldn't be anywhere near the tree
so i really i i could see there being a
lot of justification for somebody
uh insisting on taking the tree down so
for somebody uh
i i'm very surprised that officers are
recommending a tpo
that seems quite extraordinary so i'm
just really supporting some of the
comments that councillor white
council and civil have made thank you
chairman
thank you council fleming
thank you chair who knew that councillor
siddall was such a tree expert
um yes i agree i find it slightly odd
that
um we're proposing a tpo on a lolandai
um you know they're very damaging to the
structure of buildings so
yeah i have concerns about the officer's
recommendation
thank you can you catch them all
um yes i just agree with the other
counsellors
the thing is though once you start to
chop the tree about to make way for the
power line it's going to look an eyesore
anyway even more than it does now
um it's growing so fast there'll be
chopping
v-shape in it forever and a day so
cannot understand why they're preserving
a tree like that
thank you
um council miss white anything to add
well just to come back although i have
some sympathy for the officers
we're not urban oh we're not london we
have lots of nice trees we don't need
such a big
laylander right in somebody's front
garden it's just not the right location
and the tempo form
does allow that you know or makes
provision for that
so it really shouldn't have scored such
a high score anyway in my opinion so i
think they should not be confirmed
okay actually i think once again
my mouth took over and i didn't put the
recommendations so
um the recommendation is that the tpo be
confirmed
will anybody second that yeah i'll
second it
okay right quick vote
rapid fire vote please katie
yes chairman so that we are sorry
clive could you mute please sorry oh
bigger problem
we are voting to confirm the tree
preservation order
starting with councillor mrs fleming
please
against thank you thank you
councillor jarvis please
against please katie councillor keys
against players guarding councillor
morley
against thank you councillor
against thank you councillor mrs
thompson
it's hello landis i'm going to abstain
i'm
not quite sure thank you councillor mc
white
against thank you
chairman that is none for six against
and one abstention
okay right as this is a tpo and i know
the rules are a bit
different um mr lee do we have to vote
the opposite way or is that
is that a done deal now oh you put me on
the spot if i'm correct
it's a done deal because it's about
whether we confirm it or not it's not
about how
so confirming it is automatically
yeah not confirmed are you sure we're
right because
i'll i'll do the other vote if if it
says no i
am i am 95 convinced if you want to run
the
other vote just to be built on braces
but i'm nine times
i think we should i think i'd rather
look a little bit silly than
um make a mess of it so i'm so uh
all right i'm gonna put the proposal
either that didn't support it
that the tree preservation order not
be confirmed second to please
yeah i'll stick second okay right
sue councillor white was the first one i
actually heard
so uh again rapid fire uh vote please
on not confirming the team please katie
yes chairman so we're voting not to
confirm the tpo
starting with councillor mrs fleming
please
thank you councillor jarvis
thank you councillor keys
four plus guardian thank you la morley
four thank you councillor
door four thank you
counselor mrs thompson i'm still
abstaining i've still got very mixed
views
thank you and councillor miss white oh
thank you
for none against one abstention so we're
definitely not confirming okay
item 11 uh any other items of business
the chairman of the committee decides
are urgent there are none
uh item 12 is the closure of the meeting
members and officers thank you all for
your contributions this evening
i draw the meeting to a close at 20
27 um which at least is better than last
month
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to enter into any further
discussion on this forum
and to please leave the meeting promptly
thank you everyone
good night good evening to mr
you